oh my god hello angels okay
Avenger we're gonna call you Noah yeah
well what is this one
peewee I like it
he seems like a you he's a goofy
[Music]
hi I'm Brendon Urie from panic at the
disco and I'm gonna be answering your
fan submitted questions while hanging
out with puppies let's see how well I
can see okay oh my god first look hard
you beautiful okay the identity okay you
want to eat this okay since you've taken
to Broadway acting is there any chance
we could see you in other acting gigs
perhaps on TV what if it involves dogs
absolutely I will do a dog film but
Marley and me but opposite where I save
all the dogs
that's what happens well sweet okay
pushing through pushing through what's
your favorite tattoo and why oh it's
definitely a bite um it's definitely my
one that I got off my wife's eye inside
of her favorite flower which is the
yellow rose I love that one oh sorry
tiny
have you seen love Simon and if so what
did you think about Panik being featured
in I haven't seen it yet I'm going to
very soon I was very flattered a fan had
tweeted me a synopsis of all the
mentions of panic I remember getting the
email like a year and a half ago we had
talked about it and we signed up it was
under a different name I can't remember
but I was like yeah this sounds like a
really cool story and then sure enough
it ends up in the movie and like that's
the coolest thing that's like you know
the biggest compliment we see it
especially have a movie like that just
so forward-thinking I love it oh my
goodness okay party for a little bit
[Music]
if you could have one panic at the disco
lyric tattooed what would it be and
where would you put it oh jeez that's a
tough one I would just put close the
goddamn door and just right across my
ass okay great okay do fans ever quote
your finds to you when you meet them and
which one is your personal favorite yeah
the first time I got recognized for not
being in panic I went to a movie I
stepped out and these two really sweet
girls came up and said hey are you that
guy from fine and it took me a second is
the first time I was asked I was like oh
yeah yeah yeah yes I am and I started
singing this coffee one that I had done
so that was very cool thank you name is
Jessie thank you thank you just lounge
in like a little boss hi would you ever
consider doing another Broadway show and
what would your dream role be absolutely
I was raised in the Mormon faith so I
would love to be an elder price that
would be great the only problem is I
have a full sleeve of tattoos and most
missionaries are in short sleeves so
we'll see make up make up what made you
decide to call your fans sinners again I
I grew up in the Mormon Church and it
was just kind of a little juxtapose to
what I was taught was always taught that
I was a sinner I'm no good not good
enough for heaven so I just think it's
ironic it's funny
how did you know that Sarah was the one
first time I met her she was not single
and there was definitely a chemistry
there but I knew [ __ ] that she was down
and very cool because I made her a
lunchable with a capri-sun and she was
totally down it was like fancy to her
it's like over d'oeuvres it's like a
canapes it was great if you could create
or contribute to the soundtrack of any
movie which one would it be
oh I think I've said it before I would
love to do like the overdub and the
Foley for a Jason Statham movie you know
where I do like all the punches like do
his you know yelling and stuff if you
could choose one or two bands to go on
tour with you who would they be and why
one or two bands let's do them I'm just
a massive Kendrick fan Kendrick Lamar
that would be dub just let me open I'll
do a five minutes a stand-up I'll sell
your merch whatever bro let me let me
hang what is the last thing you do
before going on stage and the first
thing you do coming off stage last thing
I do before going on stage I watch the
band hit the stage and walk out it's
usually just a rush of emotions but
right before that we do our pre-show
shot to kill the hyper awareness we have
done a whiskey shot and it just all made
us grumpy so we know brown liquor before
the show so we do one shot of tequila
and then right after we come off
we like that my favorite way to come off
the stages and Elvis exit which means
you just go from stage right into a van
right to the hotel into a shower and
pass out that's the best it's just a
show for me I don't have was there an
audition process for kinky boots and if
so what was it like not really which I
was nervous for I was flattered that
they would give me the part but I was
very nervous for it basically I had DB
bonds who flew out to LA he's the
Associate Director for kinky boots he
flew out for two days we did an hour
each day of just reading through the
script talking about motivations that
was pretty much it and we had about a
week of rehearsal teaching me the dance
moves putting my heels on and then it
was Showtime and my put in rehearsal I
dropped a glass on the stage and it
shattered and my heart shattered I was
like hopefully that was the worst of it
no I would continue to [ __ ] up every
night but it was fun it was fun what's
the most memorable weird thoughtful etc
gift you have received from a fan weird
or thoughtful
I got a voodoo doll which usually you
would keep the voodoo doll but I they
gave it to me of myself so you know if
ever I feel
what does that call flagellating in a
way I'll just poke the doll come correct
what is the new album's overall genre
hmm is it gonna be all jazz like as what
you've mentioned in one of your live
sessions before no every song is
different I love doing that yeah they're
all kind of all over the place you know
there's one that feels like you're in a
club but it sounds like you're at a hot
topic if hot topic we're a club I guess
yeah would you ever consider writing
another song with f OB absolutely love
those guys
I love I love Fall Out Boy they're my
homies they've always been really
inclusive like including me and all
their stuff and they're just big
brothers always get the paper what was
some titles for this new album that you
thought about but didn't end up going
with I was gonna call it like a Lord
Byron quote which I thought was really
nice it wasn't love love not man less
but nature more it was famous of thirsty
youth which I thought was a really cool
quote but yeah it's prey for the wicked
I just thought that tight in everything
actually that I was talking about what
was your first impression of Pete Wentz
did you think you guys would have the
relationship that you have now no not at
all Pete was very cool he was in LA
making his record with Fall Out Boy and
I remember walking up being like wow
this guy looks like a rock star and then
we went back to the practice space and
played some stuff although I was a puppy
part solid Alpo gasps yeah I didn't I
didn't think that we would you know I
didn't know what was gonna come of
meeting Pete and getting signed in all
this stuff so yeah it's just it's gotten
better over time it's my big brother I
am dying to know how the performance is
differed between a panic at the disco
concert and appearing is Charlie pricing
kinky boots on Broadway very different
I'll say the biggest difference is that
with a panic show luckily the fans you
guys are louder than me sometimes and
you save me in moments where I might
forget a lyric or a voice crack happens
but in kinky boots you're up there and
spotlights on you and you if you mess up
everybody hears it you're under a
microscope and that was very exciting
coming from a person who deals with
anxiety and wants to become a performer
one day how do you cope with anxiety on
stage or even during the whole touring
process very good question I used to
take medication then I stopped taking it
just came to a realization that I
you didn't want to go there so then I
adopted the art of breathing breathing
exercises that really ended up helping
me a lot more than I thought it would
which is pretty great so thank you that
question
I know performing can be very anxiety
driven so I believe you what is your
plan for the future of panic at the
disco after this album I don't know I've
talked about like doing weird stuff like
after the Broadway thing building a show
like that taking it on the road
not necessarily with an album but just
kind of building the idea of a show it
wouldn't just be an album I don't I
don't know there's something there
there's definitely something in there
favourite Fall Out Boy song or lyric
right now I like Church that one's great
great did you guys ever actually
consider yourselves emo when you started
as a band no we never did but we
listened to a lot of bands that were
considered emo so yeah we were never
offended by it it's like if you wanted
to call us emo yeah all good which
person that you've met or which
interaction that you've had do you think
has had the biggest influence on how you
want to be seen just generally as a
person wow that's a deep question
I'm a believer in the butterfly effect
right like so if I you know everybody I
come in contact with has an influence on
something that will happen in the future
for me I got to meet President Obama on
the first lady with those Michelle and
Barack man that that was crazy waiting
in line I was so anxious and stepped in
me and my wife and watching her meet
them first I was just this is actually
happening this is really crazy very tall
very beautiful people ship my hand and I
just kind of shuddered a little bit I
said you are you were just great and I'm
a big admirer of yours and just thank
you and he said that's a very snappy
suit I thought was great okay last one
would you ever be a judge on RuPaul's
Drag Race I feel like it would be a
perfect fit for you abso lutely that
would be a blast are you kidding I would
love to be a contestant on there too and
we'll figure something out I just would
love to be in drag yeah vengers my dude
[Music]
yeah dude oh you're the sweetest yeah
you protected me hey I just want to
thank BuzzFeed man for setting this out
because what this is the focus to be
better hey by the way you guys want to
adopt the North Shore Animal League
America did you take all four it's four
times the happiness broken getting all
of this yes I need this